Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想先和大家分享一件非常令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾好奇如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续收入冲刺挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, I am talking to Matthew, who is an early career
这些原则同样适用于你。丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接参与挑战，还将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特恩特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一教练辅导的机会。你想了解更多吗？当然想。快去我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体账号，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我采访了马修（Matthew），他是一位刚开启职业生涯的
psychologist. He is in the middle of his undergraduate psychology degree, and we are talking about research, how he has managed to get himself such robust, important research experience before he has even graduated. It is a brilliant episode. I challenge you not to be riveted and so interested and inspired. I feel inspired. I feel in awe having met him. Hope you find it so useful. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified
心理学家。他目前正在攻读心理学本科的中间阶段，我们探讨了研究工作，以及他在尚未毕业时是如何积累到如此扎实、重要的研究经验的。这是一期精彩绝伦的节目。我敢说你一定会被吸引、感到无比有趣并深受启发。我自己就深受启发，见到他时我充满了敬意。希望你们也会觉得非常有用。如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让它成为你的向导吧！有这个播客在你身边，你离获得资格就不远了。
It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. I hope that you are well wherever you are listening to this in the world and whatever stage of your career that you are at. I know that people listen to this podcast or watch it on YouTube from a variety of different locations around the world and from different stages of their career. And people do pitch to me, you you know and I love receiving pitches so today's episode is the result of a pitch that someone made to me if you have ideas for a podcast topic that you think will be an interesting and useful listen to people that are on their journey as aspiring psychologists or even as qualified psychologists for that matter do please let me
欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是玛丽安·特恩特博士，我是一名具有执业资格的临床心理学家。无论此时你在世界的哪个角落收听，无论你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，我都希望你一切都好。我知道世界各地有很多人通过播客或YouTube收看和收听这个节目，他们来自不同的地方，处于职业的不同阶段。大家也经常向我投稿，你知道的，我非常喜欢收到投稿。所以今天的节目就源于某位听众的投稿。如果你有关于播客主题的想法，觉得对那些走在有志心理学家道路上的人，甚至对已经获得执业资格的心理学家们来说会是一次有趣且有用的收听，请务必告诉
know please also do remember that the aspiring psychologist collective book and the clinical psychologist book are both available there will be links in the show notes and in the description how you can get your hands on that back listens to aspiring psychologist podcast episodes can be really useful for helping you to learn and understand topics that you might feel you need strengthening do also consider the aspiring psychologist membership and you can come out and hang out with me on the aspiring psychologist community on facebook as well i hope you will find today's episode so, so useful. We do discuss some tricky kind of brain concept and structure issues, but Matthew describes it all beautifully and
我。另外请大家记住，《有志心理学家集体》一书（Aspiring Psychologist Collective book）和《临床心理学家》一书（Clinical psychologist book）现已全部出版上市，节目简介和说明中会有获取这些书的链接。回听往期的《有志心理学家播客》节目，对于帮助你学习和理解那些你觉得需要强化的主题非常有用。也可以考虑加入“有志心理学家会员计划”（aspiring psychologist membership），你还可以来Facebook上的“有志心理学家社区”（aspiring psychologist community）和我一起交流。我希望大家会觉得今天的节目非常、非常有帮助。我们确实讨论了一些棘手的大脑概念和结构问题，但马修把这一切都解释得非常优美和
brilliantly. So I hope you will find it useful. I would love any feedback that you've got. Please do. If you're watching on YouTube, let me know what you think to the content in the comments please do like and subscribe whilst you're there as well and I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side of meeting Matthew I hope you enjoy it see you soon. Hi I just want to welcome along our guest for today Matthew. Matthew is an early career psychologist he is in year three of a four-year psychology undergraduate degree. Is that right, Matthew? Yeah, that's perfect. Yeah. Lovely. All right. Well, thank you so much for coming here today. And you reached out to me on LinkedIn because you kind of, you pitched an episode to me, which I love. So thank you for
精彩。所以我希望你能从中受益。我非常期待听到你的任何反馈。如果你在YouTube上观看，请在评论区告诉我你对内容的看法，顺便点赞并订阅，我非常期待在采访马修之后与你再次交流。希望你喜欢这期节目，我们回头见。嗨，我只想对今天的嘉宾马修表示热烈欢迎。马修是一位刚开启职业生涯的心理学家，他目前正处于四年制心理学本科的第三年。是这样吗，马修？是的，完全正确。太好了。好的，非常感谢你今天来到这里。你在领英（LinkedIn）上联系了我，向我推介了一个节目主题，我非常喜欢，所以谢谢你
doing that. And it was was you wanted to kind of talk a bit about research but before we do that if we could have a little bit of a chat about you and why you chose psychology and how your study's going. Sure yeah well first of all thanks for having me you know definitely the podcast and all the content has been very helpful you know navigating career paths and and all of that so thanks for having me. But yeah I grew up in Tuam in Galway, County Galway in Ireland. I'm currently living in Galway City and I'm in my third year as you said I like exercising in my free time. I love psychology, obviously. Yeah.
这样做。你当时想谈谈研究相关的话题，但在我们开始之前，能不能先聊聊你自己，比如你为什么选择心理学，以及你的学业进展如何？当然可以，好的，首先谢谢邀请我上节目。毫无疑问，这个播客和所有的内容都非常有用，帮我指明了职业道路等等，所以谢谢你们邀请我。不过，我在爱尔兰戈尔韦郡图姆（Tuam, County Galway）长大的。我目前住在戈尔韦市，正如你所说，我读大三。我空闲时间喜欢健身。当然，我也热爱心理学。是的。
Thank you. Somewhat put you on the spot there, didn't I? So you are in Galway, which is where I recently came to do a keynote speech. And I just have to say, I absolutely loved the city and found everybody so welcoming. I think you couldn't be there that day, we haven't met in person but um yeah like just incredible and just a little plug if anyone wants to watch the vlog episode of my trip to Galway Matthew says it's quite good so I'll take that as credit thank you all right so um how come your uni is a four-year course?
谢谢。刚才好像有点突然点名提问了，对吧？所以你在戈尔韦，我最近刚去那里做了一个主旨演讲。我不得不说，我真的非常喜欢这座城市，每个人都热情好客。我想你那天可能去不了，我们还没见过面，但是……是的，简直太棒了。顺便做个小广告，如果有人想看我戈尔韦之行Vlog的观众，马修说拍得挺不错的，所以我就把这当作肯定了，谢谢你。那么，为什么你们大学的课程是四年制的呢？
So we're actually the first cohort that's doing the year three of four. So originally every other year it was first year and you do psychology and you pick two other subjects. So I pick Spanish and philosophy. And then your second year is just psychology. It's very competitive. It depends of what what grades you get you know you might have to do two subjects um but generally it was a three-year course so this year is the first time they're they're trying out a third year so people are going abroad uh to study in different universities people are doing research placements uh work placements and kind of educational settings or
实际上，我们是第一届读四年制第三年的学生。原本在其他年份，第一年你学习心理学，还要选修另外两门学科。我当时选了西班牙语和哲学。然后第二年只学心理学。竞争非常激烈，取决于你取得的成绩，你可能需要选修两门学科……但通常这是一个三年制的课程，所以今年是他们第一次尝试开设第三年，因此学生们可以去国外不同的大学学习，或者进行研究实习，以及在某种教育机构或
um maybe like charity services and uh or organizations it's been really amazing like this the modules we have this semester a lot of electives um like medical psychology kind of seeing how psychology is applied in medical settings which has been really really interesting and community psychology is definitely one of my favorites so far we're kind of learning about like stuff alternative methods methods to like the scientific method the standard one maybe how you can work with communities and looking at like the role of a psychologist less as like a power dynamic and more of how you can kind of like communities guide the whole process and
慈善服务机构或组织中进行工作实习。这真的太棒了，比如我们这学期有很多选修课模块，像医学心理学，让我们看到心理学是如何应用在医疗环境中的，这真的非常、非常有趣。到目前为止，社区心理学绝对是我的最爱之一。我们正在学习一些替代传统科学方法（即标准方法）的东西，比如如何与社区合作，把心理学家的角色较少地看作是一种权力动态，更多地看作是如何让社区来主导整个过程，并
really integrate them in in research and practices and stuff like that so i'm just talking about societal issues like misogyny racism and decolonization a lot of a lot of really broad but really important topics uh so um yes it's just been great really and the class is a lot smaller this year so we're all getting to know each other more and we're planned the night out now so it's so we're all it's a nice nice energy in the class you know oh good that sounds like a really you know it's funny you should use the word energy because you sound energized by it you sound like you're like oh my days i can't believe i get to learn this, you know, this is so exciting. I know that before we hit record, you'd said that you'd actually done a couple of years as a different undergraduate degree to begin with. Do you think
真正让他们融入研究和实践中等等。所以，我们探讨了诸如厌女症、种族主义和非殖民化等社会问题，有很多非常广泛但极其重要的话题。所以，是的，真的太棒了。而且今年班级规模小了很多，所以我们大家有更多机会了解彼此。我们现在正计划组织一次夜出聚活动，班里有一种非常不错、很棒的氛围，你知道的。哦，太好了，听起来真的很……有趣的是你用了“能量”这个词，因为听起来你对它充满了活力，感觉你像是“天哪，我竟然能学到这些东西，这太令人兴奋了”。我记得在按下录音键之前，你曾说过，一开始其实你花了好几年读了另一个本科学位。你觉得
that's kind of left you with renewed vigour to really embrace this that feels right this time? Yeah, for sure. I think I definitely felt very lucky like that i had another chance to study something else you know um just because of money and everything you know uh but yeah i left home when i was 17 so i guess i really like didn't really know you know how to like manage money properly and i guess like i was being a teenager like having fun and doing what you do when you go to college first. But I did animation first for a year and that that was a very good course. It was in Athlone. I think we were the first ever like students to do that course, though. We were the first entry year. So I guess there's a lot of issues around funding and stuff and getting materials and sometimes lectures kind of dropped out and
这是否让你重新焕发活力，全身心投入到这个感觉对头、这次选对了的方向中呢？是的，当然。我觉得自己真的很幸运，能有另一次机会去学习其他东西，你知道的……只是因为经济等原因……不过，是的，我17岁就离开家了，所以我想我当时真的不知道该如何正确管理金钱，而且我也像个青少年一样，只顾着玩乐，做那些刚上大学时会做的事。我一开始读了一年的动画专业，那是一门非常不错的课程，在阿斯隆（Athlone）。我想我们可能是第一批修读这门课程的学生，属于第一届入学。所以我想当时有很多关于资金、获取材料方面的问题，有时讲师也会中途离职，
there's a lot of stuff there so I actually changed to music then I did music for a couple months and then I left that and I decided I was going to work for a while and kind of really decide what I wanted to do so I ended up with a I applied to university but I actually got rejected because I hadn't done a language in my leave insert so I did a level five course kind of in applied social studies and there's a psychology module there and we're doing all like the the standard like Freud and very like like almost pop psychology kind of stuff and I just really enjoyed it like the case studies and we did like human growth and development um so i i just loved it and then i got into university of galway through that course um uh thankfully and then i took psychology and then i transferred from that into denominated
有很多类似的事情。所以后来我转去了音乐专业，学了几个月音乐，然后又放弃了。我决定先工作一段时间，真正弄清楚自己想做什么。最后我申请了大学，但其实被拒绝了，因为我的毕业证书（Leaving Cert）里没有学过外语。于是我在应用社会科学领域读了一个5级课程（level five course），其中包含一个心理学模块。我们在那里学习了所有标准的理论，比如弗洛伊德的理论，以及非常通俗的、类似流行心理学的东西，我真的非常喜欢，比如案例研究，我们还学习了人类生长与发展……所以我真的超级喜欢。通过那个课程，我得以进入戈尔韦大学（University of Galway），
psychology and and yeah i just i feel super lucky every day to be studying and just like really happy really engaged you know I love that and honestly that's how I feel about my life like and my career I just it beams out of me I love it I can't believe I get to do this and people listen to me and and I also get to work clinically as well and that's really helpful for people um I just yeah just I pinch myself do you see yourself going into a psychology profession um yeah ideally i'd love to go down the route of clinical psychology since the summer uh working on on that paper i i definitely geared towards like maybe clinical neuropsychology if like if that would be possible you know it's a long road but ideally you know i'd like to do something like that maybe um yeah i'd love to work in psychology i'm trying not to limit myself too
谢天谢地。然后我学了心理学，接着从那个专业转入了特定名称的心理学专业（denominated psychology）。是的，我每天都觉得自己超级幸运能在这里学习，真的非常开心、非常投入，你知道的。我太喜欢了，说实话，我对自己的生活和职业也是这种感觉。这份热情自然而然地流露出来，我太爱了。我简直不敢相信自己能做这个，人们愿意听我说话，同时我也能从事临床工作，这对人们来说真的很有帮助……我真的常常捏自己一把，看看是不是在做梦。你觉得自己未来会从事心理学职业吗？是的，理想情况下，我希望能走临床心理学这条路。自从今年夏天
much in terms of what what route i go down uh but whatever i'll be lucky enough to partake in that yes you know yeah i think you know you just you make the choices that are right for you at that time and you know you learn along the way and maybe you will like particular areas maybe you won't but it's you know keeping the things that work well for you and learning from the bits that don't go so well in the UK I think in terms of clinical neuropsychology you do your clinical psychology and then do a master's in neuropsychology um does your undergraduate confer the British Psychological Society kind of mark of approval in order to get onto UK doctorates or is it is it a little bit different with you being in Ireland? As far as I know it I think so
做过那篇论文后，我发现自己明显更倾向于临床神经心理学，如果可能的话，你知道的。这是一条漫长的道路，但理想情况下，我希望能做类似的事情……是的，我很乐意在心理学领域工作，我尽量不给自己选择的路线设定太多限制，只要是有幸能参与的领域都可以，是的，你知道的。对啊，我觉得你只要在当时做出对你来说正确的选择，并且在过程中不断学习。也许你会喜欢某些领域，也许不会，但重要的是保留那些对你管用的部分，从那些不太顺利的地方吸取教训。在英国，据我所知，如果要从事临床神经心理学，你需要先完成临床心理学培训，然后再攻读神经心理学的硕士学位。你的本科学位是否符合英国心理学会（BPS）的认证标准，以便你能顺利进入英国的博士项目？还是说你在爱尔兰情况会稍有不同？据我所知，应该是符合的，
because I know the HSE like the health services here for assistant psychologist roles they look for like degrees that are accredited by the PSI the Irish Psychological Society or the the British British one so yeah okay lovely so I guess that means hopefully you've got options available for you to train in Ireland or maybe in the UK as well yeah that would be great yeah hopefully so you mentioned your research paper there could you tell us a little bit about what you've been up to uh yeah so last year they sent out a call for kind of scholarships during the summer research internships and i sent an email to one of my uh lecturers uh dr tom burke he's a clinical neuropsychologist in the hospital in galway here and um I told him I had an interest in
因为我知道这里的健康服务署（HSE），比如初级心理学家职位，他们寻找的是获得爱尔兰心理学会（PSI）或英国心理学会认证的学位。所以，是的。太好了！我想这意味着你很有可能在爱尔兰或英国都有接受培训的选择。是的，那太棒了。希望如此。你刚才提到了你的研究论文，能给我们讲讲你都做了些什么吗？是的，所以去年他们发布了关于夏季研究实习奖学金的申请通知。我给我的其中一位讲师汤姆·伯克博士（Dr. Tom Burke）发了一封电子邮件，他是戈尔韦一家医院的临床神经心理学家。我告诉他我对
schizophrenia and kind of like social cognition um and personality disorders and different stuff like that so he recommended to apply for a neuroscience the Galway neuroscience uh scholarship um so he kind of told me like there there's a data set they've already collected they've been working on called iRelate a very big data set of people living with schizophrenia and kind of different social cognition tests and childhood trauma and genetics as well. So, yeah, he said I could work on that data set and maybe to pick a white matter track. So I did some research and came up with the unsnipped vesiculus it's a like it very no it's like a frontal white matter tract and uh he was like unbelievably helpful like super supportive i definitely wouldn't have been able to do any of it
精神分裂症、社会认知以及人格障碍等不同领域很感兴趣。所以他建议我申请戈尔韦神经科学奖学金。他告诉我，他们已经收集并正在处理一个名为iRelate的数据集，这是一个非常庞大的数据集，对象是精神分裂症患者，其中包含各种社会认知测试、童年创伤以及基因数据。所以，是的，他说我可以在这个数据集上开展工作，并挑选一个白马质束（white matter tract）。因此我做了一些研究，选中了钩束（uncinate fasciculus），这是一个位于额叶的白马质束。他真的提供了难以置信的帮助，给予了超级多的支持，如果没有他的指导，我绝对不可能完成这一切，
without his guidance uh so he guided me along and we came up with an idea for the relationship between emotion recognition, like I suppose a facet of social cog is emotion recognition, the unsinu, and childhood trauma. So we kind of looked at the relationship between those three and kind of whether physical neglect in childhood kind of mediated the relationship between social cognition and, sorry, the development of the uncindered fasciculus in the brain. With the theory being that the tract is somehow linked and important to whether someone does or doesn't develop schizophrenia,
所以他一路指导我，我们共同构思了一个关于情绪识别（作为社会认知的一个方面）、钩束以及童年创伤之间关系的想法。我们探讨了这三者之间的关系，以及童年时期的躯体忽视是否在社会认知和（抱歉）大脑中钩束的发展之间起到了中介作用。其理论基础是，该束以某种方式与一个人是否会患上精神分裂症相关且至关重要，
is that where it's rooted in uh yeah sort of kind of maybe it might be to do with social cognition um and we're kind of thinking maybe childhood trauma affects uh the development of of the that white matter tract and then through affecting that as the person grows older, their emotion recognition might be negatively affected. And then that could contribute to the development of schizophrenia that they might already be at risk for or other factors might be playing a risk. But it was really interesting in the research looking at, I suppose, how emotion recognition can play into someone who might be experiencing psychosis or at risk. They actually found that poor emotion recognition of neutral faces was predictive of transition to psychosis in people who are at risk. So someone might be talking to someone in a social setting and then they're picking up maybe an angry face from someone who has a neutral expression. And maybe
这是它的根源所在吗？是的，差不多是这样，可能与社会认知有关。我们认为，童年创伤可能会影响这个白马质束的发展，然后通过影响这一点，随着年龄增长，他们的情绪识别能力可能会受到负面影响。这反过来又可能促成精神分裂症的发展，而他们本身可能就已经面临这种风险，或者其他因素也在其中发挥了风险作用。但这项研究非常有趣，它探讨了情绪识别如何在可能经历精神精神病或面临风险的人身上发挥作用。他们实际上发现，对中性面孔的差劲情绪识别能力，可以预测高危人群向精神病的转化。也就是说，某人在社交场合与人交谈时，可能会把一个面无表情的人误认为是在生气。也许
if that person already is at risk and maybe has maybe some delusional thinking or kind of paranoid thought styles that they might start thinking, oh, this person's angry at me and could cause a lot of distress then, I suppose. Yeah, and that's got really useful utility for even for us working with people with psychosis,
如果这个人本身就处于风险之中，并且可能有一些妄想思维或偏执的思维模式，他们就会开始想：“哦，这个人对我很生气。”然后这可能会带来很大的痛苦。是的，这对于我们与精神病患者合作的工作来说，具有非常实用的价值。
because actually when we were using our listening faces, they might look quite blank, they might look quite neutral. And if that can be interpreted really like negatively or hostilely, is that a word? Then that's problematic, isn't it? So I guess this is why I love research, because it teaches us so much about the person, about their experience of the world, and, you you know how to understand and make things less less frictiony you know so that things work better all around and that people have a better experience of it you mentioned a data set there but um it wasn't one i'm familiar with could you tell us what the data set is how do you spell the data set that you mentioned um so it's like a lowercase i and
因为事实上，当我们用专注倾听的面部表情时，看起来可能相当空白、相当中立。如果这种表情被非常负面或充满敌意地解读——敌意是个词吗？——那就有问题了，对吧？所以我想这就是为什么我热爱研究，因为它教会我们很多关于个人、关于他们对世界的体验的知识，以及你知道如何去理解并减少摩擦，让事情在各方面运转得更好，让人们拥有更好的体验。你在那里提到了一个数据集，但是嗯，它不是我熟悉的一个，你能告诉我们那个数据集是什么吗？你提到的那个数据集怎么拼写？嗯，所以它就像一个小写的i，然后
then the word relate uh so r-e-l-a-t-e i'm not in i'm not you know i don't fully understand the the whole project it's a very big project uh but it's it's ongoing there's been a lot of papers published from it and it's uh they did a big kind of neuroimaging on people living with schizophrenia and social cognition tests um you know and uh kind of what what my uh supervisor uh dr burke said to me was these people have given their time you know to for us to collect this data so it's important that we kind of use it to the fullest that we can to, you know, benefit other people. So, yeah, there's actually a really interesting documentary about schizophrenia on RTE. I'm not sure it's not on RTE now, but if you look it up online, it might come up. And there's lecturers from University of Galway and from the IRLA project and the lead of that project, Professor Gary O'Donoghue.
接着是单词relate，也就是r-e-l-a-t-e。我并不是完全了解整个项目，这是一个非常大的项目，但它正在进行中，已经发表了很多论文，他们对患有精神分裂症的人群进行了大型的神经影像学研究和社交认知测试。你知道的，我的导师伯克博士（Dr. Burke）对我说的是，这些人付出了时间让我们收集这些数据，所以重要的是我们要尽可能充分地利用它，去惠及其他人。所以，是的，实际上在RTE上有一个非常有趣的关于精神分裂症的纪录片。我不确定它现在是不是还在RTE上，但如果你在网上查一下，可能会搜到。那里有来自戈尔韦大学（University of Galway）的讲师、IRLA项目的成员以及该项目的负责人加里·奥多诺休教授（Professor Gary O'Donoghue）。
And he talks about schizophrenia and about the project. the I Relate Project and the lead of that project, Professor Gary O'Donoghue. And he talks about schizophrenia and about the project. And yeah, it's really fascinating if anyone's interested. Sounds great. I can see why this is kind of evoked this interest in you. And I guess what I really love is that you're learning so much at a stage of your career where actually usually we're probably quite limited just to textbooks but you're you're seeing like real world applications and real world real world research for this and I think that lights you up you know and but but kudos to you as well Matthew because you're clearly the kind of guy that that reaches out and asks for opportunities you know like you did with coming on the podcast and like you did with even approaching the professor at Galway Uni.
他谈到了精神分裂症和这个项目，I Relate项目以及该项目的负责人加里·奥多诺休教授。他谈到了精神分裂症和这个项目。是的，如果有人感兴趣的话，这真的非常迷人。听起来很棒。我能理解为什么这激起了你的兴趣。我想我真正喜欢的是，你在职业生涯的这个阶段学到了这么多东西，而实际上通常我们可能只局限于教科书，但你看到了这方面的现实世界应用和现实世界的真实研究，我认为这让你感到兴奋，你知道的。马修，我也要向你致敬，因为你显然是那种会主动伸出援手并争取机会的人，就像你来上播客一样，也像你主动联系戈尔韦大学的教授一样。
You know, you you have the similar to me. You have the idea and you give yourself permission to to ask and to explore. And, you know, the worst they can ever do is say no. But you never know where it might lead. Yeah, I think something I've learned the last few years is that you know it's always worth taking chances you know uh a lot of the a lot of the good things that have happened over the past few years is because other people give me chances and i kind of give myself a chance in a lot of situations uh just like earlier this year i started uh i used to do boxing when i was younger i kind of lost it for a while so i went back I started MMA and that was just like you know obviously I was super nervous beforehand but it was just something like
你知道，你和我有点像。你有了想法，并且允许自己去询问和探索。你知道，他们能做的最坏的事情也就是拒绝。但你永远不知道这会通向哪里。是的，我认为我这几年学到的一件事是，非常值得去冒险。过去几年发生的好多好事，都是因为别人给了我机会，而且在很多情况下我也给了自己一个机会。就像今年早些时候我开始——我小时候练过拳击，后来荒废了一段时间——所以我回去了，开始练综合格斗（MMA）。那感觉就像，显而易见，我在事前超级紧张，但这只是一件诸如
throwing myself in there and and challenging myself with something new and kind of giving giving myself a chance to I guess to to take a chance and see what happens and it's honestly been one of the best decisions in my life you know just it's been so important for connecting myself back with my body while I'm while I'm kind of psychology can get very up here so it's kind of an important balance for me to to have both you know yeah exercise is only something I've really come to a latter stage of my current life I think it's a latter life but I'm only 42 um yeah like it just wasn't something that was around for me but I really really enjoy it now and I like you say it helps me to to balance myself kind of um yeah body and mind so with your um you know absolutely what you said is right that the
把自己投身其中，用新鲜事物挑战自己，并给自己一个机会去冒险，看看会发生什么。老实说，这成了我人生中做出的最好决定之一，你知道的，这对于让我重新与自己的身体建立连接极其重要，因为心理学有时会显得太形而上。所以对我来说，拥有这两者是一种重要的平衡，你知道的。是的，锻炼是我在当前生活中相对较晚的阶段才真正开始接触的事物，我觉得这是晚年生活，虽然我才42岁。是的，它以前并不是我生活中的一部分，但我现在真的非常非常享受。就像你说的，它帮我在某种程度上平衡了身心。所以结合你的……你知道的，完全正确，教授
professor had said we've got a duty of care really to to do everything we can with this research with these um you know this data that the people have given so freely of their time to create so what did you do with it what happened next yeah so um we had i think just about 105 um uh well 58 participants. And then I'm not sure, 116, whatever double that is. I had to basically use a software. It's a diffusion tensor imaging software. So we had all the MRI scans and then they were transferred to, I think, a DTI file. And then I used that program. It was really fascinating.
曾说过，我们确实有责任和义务利用这些研究、利用人们如此慷慨地奉献时间所创造的数据，尽我们所能去做所有事情。所以你用它做了什么？接下来发生了什么？是的，所以我们当时有大约105个……呃，对，58名参与者。然后我不确定，116个，不管翻倍是多少。我基本上得使用一个软件，这是一个弥散张量成像（DTI）软件。所以我们拥有所有的MRI扫描结果，然后它们被转换成了一个DTI文件，我想是这样的。接着我就用了那个程序，真的非常迷人。
It was a bit mind-blowing at the time. I could basically see their brain scan in kind of 3D. And part of the internship was to learn how to segment a tract. So to basically get rid of all the other white matter tracts and and single out on this specific one and then we use the measure called fractional anisotropy so kind of a measure of the the water diffusion in the in the tract and how the integrity of the tract so whether those water molecules are really like densely packed together or kind of sparse though and that can kind of i suppose by looking at other research that can give
在当时感觉有点大开眼界。我基本上可以用3D的形式看到他们的脑部扫描。实习的一部分就是学习如何分割纤维束，也就是基本上把所有其他的白质纤维束去掉，挑出这个特定的纤维束，然后我们使用了一个叫做各向异性分数（fractional anisotropy）的测量指标，这可以说是衡量纤维束中水分子弥散情况以及纤维束完整性的一个指标，也就是那些水分子是真的紧密排列在一起，还是比较稀疏。我想通过观察其他的研究，这可以为我们提供
us an indication of how well kind of functioning it is uh so um like my supervisor gave a really good uh analogy of it it's kind of like a road uh from one place to another and the white matter tract is like the road sending the information and then if there's like potholes on that road it can kind of information can get a bit damaged on the way um so basically i went through just over 100 um left and right um on the left and right sides of their brain um so the bilateral instruments uh segmented all of those and we we ran the statistics on the um on the fa values and then we had pre-collected social cognition uh tests uh data so and childhood trauma so we just kind of did some like mediation analysis and correlations and kind of seeing what was coming out of those and and yeah absolutely incredible and hearing you speak like even I don't know what
一个关于它功能运作得有多好的指示。所以，我的导师给了一个很好的类比，它有点像从一个地方到另一个地方的道路，白质纤维束就像是发送信息的道路，如果那条路上有路坑，信息在传输过程中就会有点受损。所以基本上我检查了100多条左右的大脑左右两侧的白质纤维束——也就是两侧对称的结构，把它们全部进行了分割，然后我们对FA值运行了统计分析，接着我们拥有了预先收集的社交认知测试数据和童年创伤数据，所以我们只是做了一些中介分析和相关性分析，看看会得出什么结果。绝对令人难以置信，听你说话，甚至我不知道这些
stuff is like it's amazing like even that you get to know this stuff and you get to be so competent um and you know capable at what you're talking about and what you're understanding this is massively important and you know it sounds like you you know just really found a really wonderful opportunity where you've been able to help you know a research process but you've also learned so much and you know that will be useful for you in all of your areas of your career in future you know you'll have this understanding about in all of your areas of your career in future you know you'll have this understanding about the way that the brain works and what what might stop it from working and a really important part of what we do in this profession of ours is to do the
东西是什么，也觉得太惊人了，甚至你能够了解这些东西，并在你所谈论和理解的内容上变得如此称职和有能力。这极其重要，而且听起来你确实找到了一个非常棒的机会，不仅能够协助研究过程，还学到了这么多东西。你知道，这将在你未来职业生涯的所有领域都对你大有裨益。你将对大脑的工作方式以及可能阻碍其工作的因素有所理解。在我们这一行中，非常重要的一部分工作就是为人们提供
psychoeducation for people and to de-shame a process in helping people to understand what might be going on for them and how it's not their fault and I think sometimes being able to really talk about the neurobiology of someone's brain can be really really powerful so you've absolutely got a head start in that regard. Did you publish? Are you in the process of publishing? Yeah so we're actually in the, it's a whole new learning experience, the process of publishing. It's very, you know, I mean, yeah, we're in the process of kind of communicating with reviewer feedback, peer reviewer feedback right now. So it's quite intense, but not in a bad way. You know, it's definitely a really good learning curve.
心理教育，并在帮助人们理解他们身上可能正在发生的事情以及这不是他们的错的过程中去除污名化。我认为有时候能够真正谈论某人大脑的神经生物学可以非常非常有力量。所以你在这一方面绝对占领先机。你发表论文了吗？你在发表的过程中吗？是的，所以我们实际上正处于——这是一个全新的学习体验——发表论文的过程中。这非常……我的意思是，是的，我们目前正处于与审稿人意见、同行评审意见进行沟通的过程中。所以相当紧凑，但并不是不好的那种。你知道，这绝对是一个非常好的学习曲线。
So me and my supervisor, he's actually out of the country at the moment, so we're kind of going back and forth on emails and doing all the track changes and kind of addressing some of the comments. But again, it's really helpful. I absolutely hate track changes, honestly. I hate it with an absolute passion. And I can never manage to get everything to disappear off the screen when it still says the sum there.
所以我和我的导师，他目前正好在国境外，所以我们基本上是通过电子邮件来回交流，处理所有的修订痕迹（track changes），并着手解决其中的一些评论。但话又说回来，这真的很有帮助。老实说，我绝对讨厌修订痕迹。我带着绝对的热情痛恨它。而且我从来没法在它显示总数时把屏幕上的所有东西都弄消失。
And you're like, there's nothing. Yeah, I'm more of a fan of a comment box than track changes. It doesn't play well with me. You've done well there to not say this process is frustrating and tedious because I know it absolutely can be. And then waiting, the ex be and then waiting for waiting the exquisite torture of waiting for other people to kind of do their bits can be really really difficult do you know what kind of what level of authorship you're going to be you know
而你会觉得，明明什么都没有。是的，比起修订痕迹，我更喜欢评论框。它跟我合不来。你在这里做得很好，没有说这个过程令人沮丧和繁琐，因为我知道它绝对可以是这样的。然后等待——经历那种等待别人做完他们那部分工作的精致折磨，可以非常非常困难。你知道你将要成为什么级别的作者吗？
first second third fourth how does it how does it look for you at the moment Matthew? So again like my supervisor Dr Burke he's been like really amazing in like guiding me through this process and really advocating you know I suppose for me to be a part of it and yeah so he's he's went out of his way to put me in his first author and yeah so that's how it's looking so good. That is so nice what a lovely guy I was hoping you'd say that because this sounds like your baby and you know absolutely amazing what sort of period of time are we talking about from when you first started really to to now to having it kind of you know the peer review comments and all of that jazz yeah so I think it was around the middle of May that that we kind of you know the peer review comments and all of that jazz? Yeah so I think it was around
第一作者、第二作者、第三作者还是第四作者？目前对你来说情况是怎样的，马修？同样的，我的导师伯克博士在引导我走过这个过程以及真正为我争取成为其中一部分方面，表现得真的太棒了。是的，所以他特意把我排在第一作者，所以目前情况就是这样，非常不错。太好了，真是个可爱的人。我希望你这么说，因为这听起来就像你的亲生骨肉一样。你知道，从你真正开始到现在的这个时间段，经历同行评审的意见以及所有这些爵士乐般的流程，简直不可思议。是的，所以我想大约是在5月中旬
the middle of May that we kind of were sure about what we were doing and we did a pre-registration as well and then once we kind of did that we started around I think the middle of May maybe like just before June and then we wrapped up at the end of August then because I was starting back on my this semester on the on September so so yeah just I suppose those those kind of three months was where the bulk of it was was done yeah. Amazing and then you just kind of written up since then or you wrote up in that process as well? Yeah so we did the pre-registration and then we kind of we were kind of writing bits as we were going I did like the literature search and I did kind of a almost like a meta-analysis table for that to kind of lay out everything we had and then the methods were were pretty much
左右，我们确定了我们在做什么，我们还做了一个预注册。一旦我们做完了那个，我们在大概5月中旬、也许就在6月之前开始，然后在8月底结束，因为我在9月份要重新开始这学期的课程。所以，是的，我猜大约在那三个月里，大部分工作都完成了。太惊人了，然后你从那以后就一直在写论文，还是说你在那个过程中也一直在写？是的，所以我们做了预注册，然后我们一边进行一边写一些片段。我做了文献检索，并为此制作了一个几乎类似荟萃分析表格的东西，把我们拥有的所有资料都摆出来，接着方法部分基本上也
the same for from other papers we had done just because it's pre-collected data and then it was just the results in the discussion, really, once we had everything collected. So, yeah, August was really the writing up the paper section. Okay. Incredible. What an amazing way to use your summer break in a really productive way. You know, future Matthew will absolutely thank you for this,
跟我们做过其他论文的方法差不多，只是因为这是预先收集的数据。一旦我们收集好了一切，剩下的基本上就是结果和讨论部分了。所以，是的，8月实际上就是撰写论文的那部分时间。好的。难以置信。利用暑假以一种非常富有成效的方式度过，这真是太棒了。你知道，未来的马修绝对会为此感谢你的，
because it will also, you know's it's an area of psychology that people often feel daunted by and don't understand and will kind of hide and run away from but actually you've really embraced this and you know that will pay you rich dividends you know it will look great on your forms for applications as well but it means that you will you know when you go to services you will you will look for research opportunities you will look for audit opportunities and you know you will be thinking as a research practitioner which is absolutely what we we train our psychologists to be so I'm just blown away absolutely blown away by what you've been able to achieve and you know this takes dogged determination this takes showing up day out day after day and you
因为这也将……你知道，这是心理学的一个领域，人们常常感到气馁、不理解，甚至会隐藏和逃避，但实际上你真正地拥抱了它，你知道这会带来丰厚的回报。它在你的申请表格上也会看起来很棒。但这意味着，当你去到各个服务机构时，你会去寻找研究机会，寻找审计机会，并且你会像一个研究型从业者那样思考，这绝对是我们培养心理学家所希望达到的目标。所以我简直被惊艳到了，对你所取得的成就感到绝对的惊艳。你知道，这需要顽强的毅力，需要日复一日地坚持出勤，而你
know this is likely an unpaid internship and so this is just your passion for developing your own career but helping others at the same time I think it's really really admirable yeah I think um you know I had a fantastic time I think it's also you know a credit. Yeah, I think, you know, I had a fantastic time. I think it's also, you know, a credit to a lot of the staff and the resources and support in the university as well. You know, I originally applied for a health research board scholarship that would have been more focused on kind of stroke victims and things like that.
知道，这很可能是一份无薪实习，所以这完全出于你发展自己职业生涯同时又帮助他人的热情，我认为这真的非常非常令人钦佩。是的，我认为……你知道，我度过了一段美妙的时光。我认为这也是对大学里的许多员工、资源和支持的一种肯定。你知道，我最初申请的是一个健康研究委员会（HRB）的奖学金，那个奖学金会更多地关注中风患者之类的事情。
So it was my supervisor that kind of directed me to the neuroscience scholarship and really just that um so it was my supervisor that kind of directed me to um the neuroscience scholarship and really just hands-on you know so it's definitely credit to him he really allowed me to to to be there and kind of work at it then so I definitely felt an obligation then to to make sure I did all I could you know. Okay so the scholarship means that you get some sort of remuneration does it is that Is that what the scholarship can tell you? You don't need to share figures with us. But how does it work from a scholarship angle? So the scholarship was actually eight weeks.
所以是我的导师把我引向了神经科学奖学金，并且真的是亲力亲为……所以这绝对要归功于他，他真的允许我在那里并努力工作，所以我绝对感到有责任确保我尽了自己所能，你知道的。好的，所以奖学金意味着你能得到某种报酬，是这样吗？奖学金包含这些吗？你不需要跟我们分享具体的数字。但是从奖学金的角度来看它是如何运作的？所以奖学金实际上为期八周。
So we had it. It's not just psychology. The scholarship is kind of all like medicine and a lot of different areas in the college. So you pick a supervisor, put a project and uh and then hopefully you get the scholarship and then you have eight weeks to kind of work on the scholarship together um so yeah we did that and thankfully we got the approval and uh then so that so that was a paid scholarship for two months and then the third month um thankfully they they extended extended it for another month uh just through funding of the iRelate project uh because we were still writing up the the paper so so thankfully yeah
所以我们拥有它。这不仅仅是心理学。这个奖学金涵盖了学校里所有医学以及许多不同领域。所以你挑选一位导师，提交一个项目，然后希望你能获得奖学金，接着你有八周的时间一起合作完成这个奖学金。所以，是的，我们做到了，谢天谢地我们获得了批准，然后这就变成了一份为期两个月的带薪奖学金。第三个月，谢天谢地，他们通过I Relate项目的资金支持又给我们延长了一个月，因为我们当时还在写论文。所以谢天谢地，是的，
yeah isn't it amazing though because actually you know i know that not everyone's gonna work for free but for that sort of experience you might have been like i've done it for free like i've learned so much it's been so brilliant but you know getting pay is a bonus and you know we should be paid for our time we should know that it's okay for you to earn money out of your really intricate complex skills that you've learned over time and that is real hours that you spent looking at all that data and collating it and putting it all together. And so, you know, absolutely. I know it's contentious, honorary or voluntary work, but we do deserve to be paid. We're highly skilled. And, yeah, I'm thrilled you were paid.
但这难道不是很神奇吗？因为实际上，我知道并不是每个人都会白干活，但对于那种经验，你可能会觉得“如果是免费的我也会做，我学到了这么多，这太棒了”。但拿薪水是一个额外的奖励，而且我们的时间理应得到报酬。我们应该知道，通过你随着时间推移所学到的那些极其精细复杂的技能来赚钱是完全可以的。那些是你花在查看所有数据、整理并把它们放在一起的真实时间。所以，绝对的。我知道荣誉工作或志愿工作很有争议，但我们的确理应获得报酬。我们技能高超。而且，是的，我很高兴你能得到报酬。
But, you know, I absolutely would have. I know I would have done it for free if I'd been in a position to afford it as well. Yeah. Yeah. Same. Yeah. You know, I almost forgot about it at points, you know, position to afford it as well yeah yeah same yeah you know I almost forgot about it at points you know that that it was paid as well which is great um you know I guess on the other side of things I'm happy it was paid as well because I guess I wouldn't have been able to fully do it for three months I work in a hotel as well at the uh part-time and usually during the summers I'd work full-time you know to kind of save up for my fees when I was paying them or rent or stuff like that so it felt very surreal as well to to be studying something and then be getting paid for it even though I still felt like I you know
但是，你知道，如果我当时有经济能力的话，我知道我绝对也会免费去做的。是的。是的。一样。是的。你知道，我在某些时候甚至都忘了，你知道，它其实也是带薪的，这真的很棒。嗯，你知道，从另一方面来说，我也很高兴它是带薪的，因为我想我可能无法完全无薪坚持做满三个月。我在一家酒店兼职，通常在夏天我会全职工作，你知道的，为了存钱交学费或者房租之类的事情。所以一边学习一边还能拿报酬，这种感觉也非常超现实，尽管我仍然觉得我，你知道的
I technically don't have a degree in psychology at all at the moment so it did feel a bit kind of maybe a bit of imposter syndrome but not not too much you know in in the beginning days I guess yeah and when people are doing counseling degrees or counseling psychology degrees or professional qualifications they kind of often tell me that they're having to work whilst they're whilst they're doing their doctorate qualifications and then they graduate they're professionally qualified they get like a band seven or equivalent post and then they're like all right I just have to do one job this isn't this is novel and I'm getting paid a reasonable wage wow this is radical um yeah like people do you know I worked when I was at uni as
从严格意义上讲，我目前其实还没有心理学学位，所以一开始确实有点像冒名顶替综合征的感觉，不过刚开始的时候其实也还好。我想是的，当人们在攻读心理咨询学位、咨询心理学学位或专业资格时，他们经常跟我说，他们必须一边工作一边完成博士学位，然后毕业获得专业资格，拿到七级或同等级别的岗位，接着他们就会觉得：“好吧，我只需要做一份工作，这太新奇了，而且我还能拿到合理的薪水，哇，这太激进啦。”嗯，就像人们常说的，我上大学时也工作过。
well I worked with disabled students I just I loved thinking about my undergraduate degree as an opportunity to learn stuff at the same time and I think it's a really exceptional way of making a really wise head start in your profession because it's it's not I don't I can't speak for you but for me it wasn't terrifically labor intensive I think there was a minimum maybe even a maximum of 10 hours a week including seminars you know it wasn't it wasn't a big demand on my time and so absolutely I could have done more than I even did. Thankfully this year now the third year we're doing this is not I suppose it's not contributing to our final grade so it's nice in that way to give us kind of I guess less not less pressure to do well, but still want to do well.
我也曾为残障学生工作。我只是很喜欢把我的本科学习看作是一个同时学习新知识的机会，我认为这是在你的职业生涯中抢占先机的一种非常卓越的方式，因为，呃，这并不——我不能代表你，但对我来说，它并不是那种极其繁重的工作量。我想每周最少可能甚至最多也就10个小时，包括研讨会在内。你知道，它对我的时间要求并不高，所以绝对的，我甚至可以做得更多。值得庆幸的是，今年，也就是我们攻读的第三年，这不算——我想它不计入我们的最终成绩，所以从这个角度来看挺好的，我觉得压力不会那么大——倒不是说取得好成绩的压力变小了，而是我们依然想取得好成绩。
But I suppose more space to focus on what we're learning as opposed to pressure on assignments, which is really nice. Yeah. And also, you know, given your age, it gives you all of your cohort more time for your own brains to develop to be able to get yourselves to be in the position where you're able to really immerse yourself in your final year to get your best possible grade so that you are performing optimally so that's kind of it's kind of nice you get a bonus year to learn to see what excites you to see what you like what you don't um and yeah you get these little information nuggets that you just get to store but you suddenly like oh i remember something about that and then you yeah you just it builds that level of confidence i think to be able to think about things in future so oh lovely lovely
但我想，它留出了更多空间让我们专注于所学知识，而不是被作业压力压得喘不过气，这真的很棒。是的。而且，鉴于你们的年龄，这给了你们整个同龄群体更多的时间，让你们的大脑得以发育，从而让你们处于这样一种状态：能够在最后一年真正全身心投入，争取获得最好的成绩，发挥出最佳水平。所以这感觉挺不错的，你得到了一个额外的学年去学习，去看看什么能让你兴奋，去发现你喜欢什么、不喜欢什么。而且，是的，你会得到这些小小的知识碎片，你可以把它们储存起来，然后突然觉得：“哦，我记得关于那个的事情！”接着，你就会——它确实建立起了那种自信，让你能够在未来思考问题。噢，太棒了，太棒了。
lovely to talk to you but why if someone is perhaps an earlier career psychologist than you maybe they're doing um you know they're still in their sixth form education and they're thinking oh i don't know about psychology you know should i shouldn't i isn't everyone doing that what's the point what would you say why should people consider doing a psychology undergraduate degree yeah i think um i think psychology is incredibly unique in that um i suppose the more you immerse yourself and learn about the subjects it it can kind of run in tangent with your own personal growth you know the things you learn i suppose as you get older or you go through different
很高兴能和你交流。但是，如果有人可能是一个比你更初期的心理学从业者，也许他们还在读预科（Sixth Form），然后他们在想：“噢，我不太确定心理学怎么样，我是该学还是不该学？是不是每个人都在学这个？这有什么意义呢？”你会怎么说？为什么人们应该考虑攻读心理学本科学位？是的，我想……我想心理学是极其独特的，因为……我觉得你越是沉浸其中、越是了解这些学科，它就越能与你的个人成长并行不悖。你知道，随着你年龄的增长或者经历不同的……
experiences it can it can change like how you learn about the things in your course or like you said those nuggets can kind of pop up again and like, Oh yeah, that I learned that last year, but it makes more sense now after you've experienced something or you think a bit more. I think it's so applicable to all situations of your life, kind of, I suppose, like introspective situations, thinking about your own kind of, I suppose, internal human condition and stuff. And then kind of outside of yourself as well. i was saying i work in a hotel so i'm an accommodation supervisor so we kind of have you know cleaners and and guests and that that's a very kind of
经历，你对课程中事物的学习方式可能会改变，或者就像你说的，那些知识碎片可能会再次涌现，然后你会想：“噢，对啊，我去年学过这个，但现在经历了一些事情或者思考得更多之后，它变得更好理解了。”我认为它非常适用于你生活的方方面面，比如，我觉得，内省的情况，思考你自身内部的人性状况等等。然后，除了你自身之外也是如此。就像我刚才说的，我在一家酒店工作，所以我是个住宿主管，我们要面对清洁工和客人，那是一种非常……
interactive interpersonal position you know where i guess like one example was was uh we had a guest that was very angry one time she was just very upset you know right right I guess like one example was we had a guest that was very angry one time. She was just very upset, you know, rightfully so. She left her phone charger in the room and she was very upset because everybody who was talking to her seemed to say, no, it's not in the room. It's definitely not there. And I had talked to her on the phone and the first thing I said to her was like, you know, I believe you. I believe that the charger was in the room and uh it's it's i just tried to validate her feelings first and then then let her know um we have a procedure for lost
互动性、人际交往很强的职位。你知道，我猜其中一个例子就是，我们曾经有一位非常生气的客人，她当时非常沮丧，你知道的——确实有充分的理由。她把手机充电器落在房间里了，她非常沮丧，因为所有跟她说话的人似乎都对她说：“不，充电器不在房间里，绝对不在。”我跟她在电话里沟通过，我跟她说的第一句话是：“你知道吗？我相信你。我相信充电器是在房间里的。”呃，我只是试图先确认她的感受，然后才告诉她，我们有失物招领程序……
property it's just not here but i do believe you that's she was kind of more upset that people weren't didn't seem to be hearing her you know um so i think uh little situations like that is just where i feel like uh before I started the degree, it's really just, and to now, it's really just opened up my mind on so many different areas of myself personally, but also externally as well. Brilliant. What a brilliant real-world example. And, you know, it's really annoying to lose your phone charger because then you can't charge your phone. And I speak from a very recent experience of my iPad charger having broken.
它只是不在这里，但我确实相信你。她其实更生气的不是东西不见了，而是大家似乎都没有在听她说话。所以，我觉得……像这样的小情况，让我觉得在我开始攻读学位之前，以及到现在，它真的为我打开了眼界，让我能够从很多不同的方面去了解自我，同时也了解外部世界。太棒了！多么精彩的现实生活中的例子。而且，你知道，弄丢手机充电器真的很烦人，因为那样你就没法给手机充电了。而且我是以最近刚把iPad充电器弄坏的亲身经历来说的。
And to replace it 48 pounds like it's not it's not a small amount of money you know and if you have to layer on the fact that oh no I've forgotten it and there's all that you know blame and shame and all of that like I've caused my own misery like it's really challenging but yeah it sounds like you're a wonderful member of that team to be able to kind of draw everything together. And, you know, I love what you say about the human condition. It's absolutely true. If you've got any advice for anybody that's specifically Matthew-ish, you know, about how to reduce burnout when you're an aspiring psychologist, what would you say? I think socialising is incredibly important.
要花48英镑才能买个新的，这可不是一笔小钱，你知道的。如果你还得再加上一层心理负担：“天哪，我居然把它给忘了”，然后伴随着所有的责备、羞耻感以及诸如此类的情绪——“是我给自己招惹了这些麻烦”——这真的很有挑战性。不过，听起来你是团队里一个非常棒的成员，能够把所有这些线索都串联起来。而且，我很喜欢你关于人类本性的说法，这绝对是真的。如果你对任何人——特别是像马修这样的人——有什么建议，关于如何在作为一名有志于成为心理学家的人时减少精疲力竭（burnout）的感觉，你会怎么说？我认为社交极其重要。
You know, if you're introverted, that's okay not to force yourself to be someone else but i suppose find um social situations where you feel comfortable you know something you have an interest in maybe it's society in college or um maybe something simple like asking a friend to go to the arcade or play soccer or whatever whatever you're interested in you know personally for me it was it was kind of starting up something I had an interest in. It may have happened in my younger self. I used to like boxing. So I started the MMA again. And that was a place where I could just go
你知道，如果你性格内向，那也没关系，不要强迫自己去扮演另一个人。但我想，去寻找那些能让你感到舒适的社交场合，比如你感兴趣的事物，也许是大学里的社团，或者是一些简单的事情，比如邀请朋友去游戏厅、踢足球，无论你对什么感兴趣。就我个人而言，它是……开始做一些我曾经感兴趣的事情。可能在我比较年轻的时候，我以前挺喜欢拳击的。所以我重新开始练综合格斗（MMA）。那是一个我可以去的地方，在那里我可以……
and fully be in my body and leave all psychology or anything just outside the door. And that was very helpful for like reducing that kind of burnout. I think where burnout comes in is when it's just constantly running on your mind. And if you have a half an hour free, you're anxious because you're thinking about forgetting something or, you know, an assignment or something. So I think doing something where you can be fully in your body is very helpful. Yeah, and you described so beautifully the process of mindfulness there and why it can be so empowering and, you know, wholesome,
完全沉浸在自己的身体里，把所有的心理学知识或其他任何事情都抛在脑后，关在门外。这对于减少那种精疲力竭感非常有用。我认为精疲力竭产生的原因在于，它一直在你的脑海里运转。如果你有半小时的空闲时间，你也会感到焦虑，因为你在想着自己是不是忘了什么事，或者在想某项作业等等。所以我认为做一些能让你完全专注于身体的事情非常有帮助。是的，你刚才非常优美地描述了正念（mindfulness）的过程，以及它为什么能赋予人力量、为什么如此健康……
whereas actually mindfulness gets a bit of a yawny, bad rep, I think. But what it is is it's just allowing yourself to literally do what you're doing in that moment without being distracted by all of the noise and the chatter and for me like every lunchtime when I'm at home I will that's awful I'm not eating a mindful lunch because what I'm doing is I've got like these games that I play on my iPad homescapes and gardenscapes I am a bit of a homescapes and gardenscapes geek but it allows me to literally just focus on that and the enjoyment of my food without all the noise in the chat or the kids stuff that I've got to do and my clients
然而事实上，正念现在往往会得到一些让人哈欠连天、不太好的名声，我认为是这样的。但它实际上所做的，只是允许你自己字面意义上去做你当下正在做的事情，而不被所有的噪音和杂音所分心。对我来说，比如每天午休我在家的时候，这就很糟糕了——我并没有在进行有正念的午餐，因为我正在做的事情是，我在iPad上玩一些游戏，比如《梦幻家园》（Homescapes）和《奇妙庄园》（Gardenscapes）。我确实有点沉迷于《梦幻家园》和《奇妙庄园》，但这让我能够字面意义上只专注于那个游戏以及食物带来的享受，而不用去管那些杂音、闲聊、我必须去处理的孩子们的琐事、我的客户……
and the podcast and, you know, my aspiring psychologist stuff. And I just, it gives me a really wonderful, mindful break in the day. So I absolutely hear what you say and I love it and support it. Yeah, for sure. I think, you know, that was something I definitely had to kind of learn by fire, I suppose, like in my second year or even in my first year. You know, we have in the university, the points are quite high to get into denominated psychology so we have a there's a system where the top 15 people in the class uh can or maybe a bit more than that can transfer to denominated if you didn't get it originally by by leaving cert points so i suppose there's a lot of pressure you know in first year on people you know and people might not even want to tell them each other what their goal is you know everyone's kind of looking at each other a bit competitively and uh then kind
还有播客，你知道的，还有我作为有志于成为心理学家的人要处理的事情。这在一天之中给了我一个非常棒的、充满正念的休息时间。所以我完全理解你所说的话，我也非常喜欢并支持它。是的，当然。我想，这绝对是我在第二年甚至第一年时不得不“在烈火中淬炼”去学习的东西，我猜是这样的。你知道，我们在大学里，考入指定心理学专业的录取分数相当高，所以我们有一个制度，班上前15名的人——或者可能比这多一点——可以转入指定专业，如果你最初没有通过毕业证书考试的分数（leaving cert points）考进去的话。所以我想，在第一年的时候，大家身上都有很大的压力，而且大家甚至可能不想把自己的目标告诉彼此，每个人看彼此的眼神都带有一点竞争性。然后……
of when you start second year the workload goes up and it's kind of already a bit burned out from first year so I really have to learn to kind of yeah prioritize kind of my my physical health and mental health I'm just in awe of you Matthew and that is what I will say in your intro and outro like I'm excited for your career in future I would like you to keep me posted on how things go and thank you for empowering so many people to think about how they can gain research experience or any opportunity for that matter I think it's going to be such a wonderfully well received episode so thank you for pitching it to me and thank you for the really important work that you're doing and
当你开始读第二年时，工作量增加了，而你其实已经对第一年感到有些精疲力竭了，所以我真的必须学会去——是的，优先照顾好我的身体健康和心理健康。马修，我对你佩服得五体投地，这是我会在你的节目开头和结尾时说的话。我很看好你未来的职业发展，希望你能随时向我通报事情的进展，也谢谢你赋能这么多人，让他们去思考如何获得研究经验，或者就此而言的任何机会。我认为这将会是一期非常受欢迎的精彩节目，所以谢谢你向我提出这个节目构想，也谢谢你正在从事的非常重要的工作。而且……
yeah let me know how your degree classification goes next year for sure yeah thanks so much for having me and for all the content as well and the book everything has been incredibly helpful so thanks so much oh well you're so welcome like i said i just love it it doesn't feel like work it feels like a privilege to do what i do and i hope that you continue to feel that way about about this profession so thank you so much um look after wonderful goalie i'm sure i'll be back in future yeah definitely thanks so much thank you thank you oh my gosh what a guy what an inspiration um i really would love you to like this episode and give matthew some kudos because he's just oh he's like a force to be reckoned with isn't he and he does it all with such a laid back approach
是的，明年记得告诉我你的学位最终评定等级进展如何。当然！非常感谢邀请我来，也谢谢你提供的所有内容、那本书，一切都对我有极大的帮助，所以真的非常感谢。噢，别客气！就像我说的，我太喜欢这份工作了，它不像是工作，做我所做的事是一种特权，我希望你能继续对这个行业保持这种感觉。所以非常谢谢你，呃，照顾好棒极了的戈尔韦（Galway），我确信以后我还会回来的。是的，绝对的，非常感谢！谢谢！谢谢！噢天哪，这人真棒，太令人鼓舞了！我真的很希望你能给这期节目点个赞，给马修一些认可，因为他真的是——噢，他就像一股不可忽视的力量，对吧？而且他做这一切都是用那种如此轻松随意的态度……
like um oh i just did this thing did this you know correlated this did that looked at that what a guy you know just really inspirational and so yeah i hope that you find it awe-inspiring i hope that it helps you think about what what your achilles heels might be and how you might go about strengthening them so yeah let me know what you think do um yeah do please watch the galway episode that we spoke about as well it's about my experiences of being a keynote speaker for the irish psychological society you may also find it helpful to watch the replay Q&A sessions, which you can do by going to my YouTube channel, going to the live videos or clicking on the playlist option for Q&A sessions. People say really wonderful things about them as being helpful for their psychology applications. And then also there's some there for interviews as well.
比如，“噢，我只是做了这个，做了那个，把这些关联起来了，看了那个。”真是一个了不起的人，你知道的，真的超级鼓舞人心！所以，是的，我希望你觉得这番对话极其鼓舞人心，希望它能帮你想想你自己的“阿喀琉斯之踵”可能是什么，以及你该如何去强化它们。所以，是的，告诉我你的想法。对了，请务必观看我们谈到的那个关于戈尔韦的节目，那是关于我作为爱尔兰心理学学会（Irish Psychological Society）主题演讲嘉宾的经历。你可能也会发现观看答疑（Q&A）环节的回放很有帮助，你可以通过访问我的YouTube频道，点击直播视频，或者点击答疑环节的播放列表选项来观看。人们对这些内容的评价极高，认为它们对申请心理学专业非常有帮助。此外，那里还有一些针对面试的指导。
Thank you so much for being part of my world i look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the podcast which will be along to you from 6am on monday take care if you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我期待在周一早上6点发布的下一期播客中与你相聚。保重！如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客陪伴在侧，你将踏上获得专业资格的道路。这就是《有志心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。
With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay
与马修·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）同行。我叫亚娜（Jana），我是一名见习心理福祉从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现里面关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。通往这个职业的道路竟然有这么多不同的选择，而且成为临床心理学家并没有一条完美的最优解，这让我感到十分惊叹。这让我充满了信心，让我觉得自己并没有做错，从而减轻了自身的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就绝对不会把它放下来。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。